Captain America is a Marvel film from
about 10 years 10 years ago right more
than that now it's about a scrawny
uh developmentally like uh um physically
uh a weakling a weakling born with a
weak heart perhaps a a like someone
suffering from many physical ailments
who is so desperate to fight for his
country to help others that he tries to
cheat his way into the military
and he is of of such strong heart he has
chosen for the super soldier program
so here's a guy of good moral characters
standing and honor who wants to serve
his country fight against the bad guys
and sacrifice whatever it takes for his
community
he defends his friends by fighting in
the streets and then there's that scene
where he jumps on the grenade his
motivation is to sacrifice himself for
everyone else self-sacrifice
self-sacrifice Captain Marvel's
motivation was to benefit herself and to
be able to do whatever she wanted
Captain America
his whole motivation is we don't we
don't trade lives we're not going to
sacrifice one for any he's a
deontological moralist Thanos is
utilitarian Thanos wants to kill half
the universe save half the life
Captain America says we don't trade
lives Captain Marvel Robs a guy in the
beginning of the in the movie he's he
says you should smile so she steals his
clothes and his motorcycle think about
that motivation that is the woke
feminist motivation of I can do whatever
I want then think about the other
character motivations Jude Law's
character says control your emotions and
then finally at the end she goes no and
that is her ultimate motivation the
story arc for her is she can do whatever
she wants because she's powerful and she
shouldn't have to listen to any man who
tells her to control herself Captain
America's motivation is I will die for
you so you can live a better life it is
the Hillary Clinton quote personified
when she said women are the real victims
of war because their husbands and their
brothers and their sons die that's
that's that exemplifies it perfectly
that's amazing self-sacrifice versus
self-validation that is the difference
between the way I was taught to write
and draw superheroes and the way
superheroes are being presented today
right there everything is a you know all
of these new superheroes that are coming
out of Marvel they're all selfie taking
self-aggrandizing narcissists eating
lunch and dinner together at diners
that's what they're doing there's no you
know my book cyber frog cyber frog says
in the in the very you know in the very
first couple of pages you know he just
says because people don't like him he's
ugly he's cyber frog so he says I've
found something to love about humans and
I'm willing to die for them you know and
that's that's the thing that's heroism
to me how many modern superheroes
are stories of young kids who wish they
had superpowers
modern ones not too many you don't think
so I'm not sure well maybe
um who are you thinking about I'm
thinking about the Captain Marvel uh uh
Miss Marvel Miss Marvel yeah right so
there's a story of like wow I've got two
powers and I'm gonna be an Avenger too
well that's me that's the meta nature of
Hollywood now that everything has to be
meta
Shazam uh no not not so not so much not
so much you don't think he wanted the
the Wizards Powers uh that he got he got
pulled in and brought into it it was
different I'm thinking about just like
I'm thinking about Miss Marvel
specifically and I was thinking about
Miles Morales you know in the in the
news into the spider verse he's like wow
I got spider powers too and then I was
thinking about growing up watching X-Men
and an X-Men typically the kids who got
powers were panicked and scared and and
didn't want it to happen and the parents
were freaking out and this the story
with you know early the X-Men stuff I
grew up on was it was actually bad to be
a mutant it was scary it was bad and
they weren't happy about it it was often
depicted as like your mutant Powers were
a curse not a gift and then Charles
Xavier would be like no no don't worry
like I'm going to help you through this
nowadays the mentality among younger
people is more so like I want to give me
power give me power yeah
I felt like DC was all all maybe not
always but I didn't read a lot of DC but
it felt like DC was more
just about raw power and Marvel was
about psychological
stuff did you guys get that Vibe yeah I
mean do you see Comics I like DC better
aspirational Heroes Heroes to look up to
you know Heroes to feel hope they're
going to save you see that's the thing I
love about Superman that they they
flopped with the new movies I mean when
you see Christopher Reeve
you know everything's gonna be okay you
know he like you're like oh Superman's
here finally I'm terrified of the Man of
Steel version of Superman from the Zack
Snyder movies can I just can I just
complain about the scene in Batman v
Superman where Batman is about to you
know kill Superman and then he's like
you're letting him kill Martha and then
Batman goes your mom's name is Martha my
mom's name is Martha too she actually
friends their mom by their name what
should have happened and I'll say it
every single time is that when Batman
had the spirit of Superman's neck what
would have made it work is then Batman
sang the famous line let this be the day
you never forget the day I defeated you
and then I should have just reconnected
they should have just recreated that
scene and then he throws the spear away
and he says my intention was always to
make sure you knew you were not
Invincible not to actually kill you and
then it would be like damn that but
instead he was like my mom's name's
Martha too Wanna Be Friends I was like
oh no yes
of kryptonite I could have made this far
stronger and killed you much easier if I
wanted to yeah it should have been he
proved his point it was never because
Batman's not a murderer yeah he wouldn't
arbitrarily want to kill her man his
point was to make sure Superman knew he
wasn't a God you know instead
all this like my mother is your mother
we're brothers all this crap this like
nepotism is like European uh monarchies
they're all cousins like it's a bunch of
this crap it's like psychological
manipulation to make you think it is
some value if the guy's your brother
he's an idiot he's an idiot this is uh
what I was always told is that Marvel
was people trying to be heroes and DC
was Heroes trying to be people there you
go so like
I I noticed watching the Justice League
cartoons they always refer to each other
as their first given names Batman
doesn't call Superman Superman calls him
Clark Clark calls him Bruce they refer
to each other as people but they are
heroes and then the interesting thing is
Superman's identity is Superman Kal-El
and his secret identity is Clark Kent
whereas in Marvel often it's like Peter
Parker is the person in the secret and
secret identity is or like his you know
the costume is Spider-Man whereas for
Superman the costume is Clark Kent who
are you guys favorite superhero of all
time
Superman
I just as the definitive hero I believe
Batman Batman you like Batman better
that's why I was really disappointed by
the movie uh I love the the uh comic fan
Trope of given enough time Batman can
defeat anyone I love God they called
that a DC they call it like yeah Batman
with enough planning but I feel like
Superman could kill Batman at any time
if he wanted to nope tonight yeah but he
blasts them for morbid
technically I would say technically but
I guess the issue is there are a lot of
super powerful villains who are on par
with Superman that haven't been able to
take down Batman because the because
Batman is a figment of our imagination
what makes him a good character is his
ability to survive and overcome with no
superpowers that's why I like Batman
granted he's a very very rich dude you
know and he's able to buy this stuff
you know it is what it is the fantasy is
we could be Batman yep we can train
ourselves we could have enough money we
could be Batman that's the whole thing
but you can't you know fly you can't do
those things Batman's just a dude but
he's a martial artist he trains right he
eats right he gets beat up he gets
injured sometimes he gets back he gets
his back broken and he rises back up to
the challenge that's that's that's a
superhero man that's fantastic I mean
early early Batman was silly and they
made him really amazing throughout the
years I do I really love the the history
of how like the Golden Age of comics was
kind of hokey Superman could fire a
little Superman's from his hand did you
know that yeah as well it makes no sense
you know whatever they invented new
powers all the time in this overage yeah
it's whatever it's a silver age the 80s
no Silver age was from like the 50s to
the 70s I think the early 70s it was a
golden age before that golden age was
the like yeah the 1930s or late 30s to
the early 50s but I want to say the 80s
is when things I think got really mature
yeah and the writing got really good
um and then actually I think one of the
most profound moments in Comics but I
guess it's technically cartoons is the
uh Mr Freeze the story arc the
retconning of his history in the Batman
animated series I think the first
cartoon ever went in Emmy
and that was for I think that was was it
really that the first maybe not the
first time but one of the first times a
villain's story arc was sympathetic it
used to be all one-dimensional I'm gonna
rule the world I deserve power that's
what I love about the old Batman the
Animated Series it's actually super
anti-corporate all of them are just
generic corporate villains but Mr Freeze
was actually a fairly three-dimensional
character given the story with his wife
and that what wasn't clayface's story in
the animated series that he was a guy
who was negatively impacted by a
cosmetic product that turned him into a
monster there were a bunch of different
clay bases one was an actor you know I
think they're like five different clay
he was like people on a cosmetic and
then started his skin started to melted
man bat was great in that too man bat
was great yeah but uh it's Mr Freeze
right yeah right he was always
one-dimensional and then he made his
story arc that his wife was dying and he
would stop at nothing to save her life
and then you're like you feel bad
because he's a bad guy plus the delivery
on all that dialogue in that in that
episode is so good yeah you should do an
arc where he gets an honorary degree
from Harvard and he's like I'm Dr freeze
now no you're not it's not even a real
degree I'm just kidding now now it's
gonna now I just wait there's gonna be a
comic that comes out soon where Mr
Freeze teams up with Greta tunberg to
reduce it
no that's why I brought it up
please I look I hope they I hope they
keep producing this garbage and they
destroy themselves and then you know
your Comics all caps we're here comic
skates here to to step in and and you
know that's that's a good see we love
comic books I could talk about this all
day long I grew up with these
superheroes I love these superheroes
I've been a Creator I've worked on these
superheroes for uh most of my life now
but uh unfortunately the the way things
are at Marvel and DC they're
inhospitable remember what was that
super well comic they made with safe
space and it never came out
they never released what is it what is
it the new Warriors yeah new new
Warriors I wonder if that was a joke
like I feel like that whole thing was uh
hopefully became one yeah it sure did
what a horrible concept look at this
okay for those days for those that don't
know you need to understand that the the
hugging brother and sister right there
brother and sister yeah Snowflake and
safe space in one of them they actually
described one of them they actually
describe as being a stereotypical jock
which I've never seen a stereotypical
jock with pink hair but that's just me
wait wait the best one is the door of
the Explorer Trailblazer is that that
they call it a chubby Inuit yeah who had
a backpack that she could pull anything
out of in the other one door of the
Explorer and the other one is is uh
powered by internet gas yeah the
internet what were oh yeah that guy this
had just been a joke it was a troll it
must have been it wasn't it
introducing yeah it's real I mean if
they've released it people would have
bought that that I would have bought
that this this is this is an important
story for for those that are that don't
understand the culture War what happened
in my opinion is that Marvel started
getting a bunch of emails saying you
need to do this and then someone went to
a board me and said this is what kids
want you gotta sell a product they'll
buy and they went you're right then they
made it and they got roasted and said we
don't understand they're emailing us
saying they want this because they don't
realize it is a it is a cult of annoying
loud people and they wasted tons of
money and they're destroying themselves
by supporting this thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time